I just think I'm post celebrity
relationship probably in my life really
John Mayer has no interest in another
high profile romance not even with mega
babe Kourtney Kardashian and there were
all these rumors that you were like
coming after her at a party yeah that
happens not to be true John made the
revelation on Andy Cohen Sirius XM show
on Monday shutting down gossip that he
and the reality star are a thing and he
explained how those rumors got started
in the first place I ran into Courtney
at a party that I kind of crashed there
was a GQ party and I crashed it towards
the end I ran into the bass player from
the scorpions and he started throwing me
in a video hey B in a video and I was
hamming it up because I love the
scorpions and then Kourtney Kardashian
walks up and I said to Courtney Courtney
walk away he's the bass player from the
scorpions gonna try to get you in a
video all I did was save Kourtney
Kardashian from being in a video with
the bass player from the scorpions guys
here's where it gets really juicy John
said he thinks someone in the Kardashian
camp could be responsible for spreading
the false story I gotta be honest with
you a little suspicious about the origin
of the story not sure the calls not
coming from inside the house on this one
I would not put it past the Kardashians
to spread this rumor John Maher is a
catch now you might remember that before
the gossip mill kicked into overdrive
with rumors about John in court he did
have a few seriously high-profile
relationships with stars like Jennifer
Aniston Katy Perry and Jessica Simpson
can we just take a sidebar for a second
and throw back to that time he told
Playboy magazine that Jessica Simpson
was and I quote sexual napalm that
moment lives on in my mind is the most
epic of all TMI sled moments anywho back
to John in court and I will say if it
the call is coming from inside the house
it's diabolical and genius the only part
that made me upset to any degree was
that somebody said that when I saw
Courtney that I said it was sweet
serendipity running into you but I
didn't say that right that's hyper corny
right uh yeah barf
but John went on to say he really
actually likes the famous fan if you
break it down to your interactions with
them yes they're very nice nice P very
and guys
favorite Kardashian is not court it's
the family's matriarch Kris Jenner I
think she is like the Yoda of Hollywood
seratonin like shays she has a good
grasp on how to make your serotonin just
bursts in your brain all right so that's
that on those John and Courtney dating
rumors of course won't be here to keep
you up to date on all things John Mayer
so be sure to keep it locked on ET until
next time I'm Hallie Stevens bye for now